one whole minute of logos two of which
were for the same company this a spark
B How to Train Your Dragon franchise is
based on British children's books and
Berk is a semi dirty word to British
children Berk means nothing to America
kids for the US version they should have
changed the village name to fart this is
Park also narration and the same
narration that started and ended the
first movie dragon racing these Berk
assholes are the most progressive in
human history going from hating dragons
for Bulls reasons to having dragon races
in just five years after learning they
weren't so bad after all
also discount Quidditch that's nine for
the turns of course the twins are
winning they're two people when they
have the dragon with the two heads
giving them an unfair advantage
now dragons used to be a bit of a
problem here but that was five years ago
everyone was terrified of dragons and
they constantly burned down the village
yes that was a bit of a problem but they
domesticated dragons in only five years
come on the Dragons fly into the stable
for an expositional tour even though the
race isn't over we have custom stables
all-you-can-eat feeding stations a full
service dragon wash shirt could not
possibly have the infrastructure to
support this nonsense but I'm guessing
they sold high on all this dragon tears
even top-of-the-line fire prevention if
I do say so myself
as long as the dragon starts a fire
right under this exact spot otherwise
they're screwed also this isn't
preventing any fires it's just putting
them out they found a way to fireproof
their buildings with some sort of
magical paint then I'd be impressed this
town exchanged their dragon cruelty for
sheep cruelty too bad they don't have a
toothless to show them the error of
their ways adult sheep can weigh well
over a hundred pounds yet these kids are
able to throw it around hold it with one
arm and do backflips and without
breaking a sweat
excuse me this guy is not only wielding
a weapon that would be nearly impossible
to carry but he hits his friend in the
face with it and he isn't dead the next
time we see him he is completely fine
people who drive like this this movie
out does the look of the first movie
which was already amazing so amazing
I'll take off a few sins for what in the
name of wily coyote is this bullshit it
seems a little reckless for toothless to
be spitting fireballs at hiccup
especially after he seemed reluctant to
do this in the first place they both
survived this luckily for them there was
a much softer rock pillar directly
behind the one he almost slammed into
no that doesn't want you what dragon
slaughter that doesn't wash out isn't
that essentially water and you're in a
society with all you can eat dragon
buffets astrid manages to find hiccup in
this uncharted area hiccup and toothless
crashed into 76 seconds of flirting
youths I know that I'm not my father and
I never met my mother so does that make
me hiccup tossing in this bit about
never knowing his mother has less to do
with him knowing who he is and more to
do with letting the viewers who didn't
see the first movie now because it's
important to the story later the Emerald
City nor did the Wizard of Oz merge with
the fortress of solitude what happened
here I know what happened
Elsa got banished again Viking
lightsaber how do you suppose we explain
this master drago bludvist Drago
what fist pretty rich of a dude named
hiccup from Berk to make fun of anyone's
name also both Drago's parents and
ancestors are assholes
he's expecting a new shipment of dragons
for his army by tomorrow instead of just
killing the kids and taking their
dragons the dragon hunters explain their
entire mission to them these dragon
hunters are inexplicably unarmed so
hiccup and Astrid are able to free the
dragon and fly off with no trouble at
all we'll follow those trappers to Drago
and talk some sense into him why is it
that the heroes of these movies always
think that the guy described as a madman
sounds like someone you can talk sense
into so either hiccup didn't take the
five minutes to land and explain his
plan to Astrid or he's making it up as
he goes along
just what every dragon trapper needs one
end coats the blade and monstrous
nightmare saliva the other sprays
hideous zippleback gasp all it takes is
a spark can pick up surrenders his
weapon for the sole purpose of
explaining how it works also this
doesn't kill them
snotlout what are you doing now these
people keep finding hiccup if he doesn't
tell anyone where he's going and from
what I've seen this is uncharted
territory Mikey this girl is actually so
enamored with Kit Harington she's
willing to be captured by it with the
likelihood of scoring very look hiccups
mother is wearing her grand wizard of
dragons mask because when she goes
flying around she needs to look
potentially evil hiccups mom is able to
stand on this dragon without losing her
balance or getting knocked off because
movie forgot how wind works toothless
doesn't round twice in the series
gasp she recognizes hiccup small
basically unnoticeable scar that no one
has ever mentioned before also a mom
knows who our kid is after last seeing
him as a baby and because of a scar that
she forgot about long ago because she
was whisked away five seconds after he
got it a mother never forgets so I guess
we figured out what happened to Merida
after the end of brave no need for brave
to Pixar we're warning you Stella can
Dawber conveniently happened along the
hole in the ice where toothless fell
where hiccups helmet is conveniently
floating find them skunk Russia dragons
can apparently pick up sense like
bloodhounds even though this mask has
been sitting in ice cold water all this
time why not you try looking up a
Wikipedia page on dragons and finding
that ability also how have we not
already done this with another one of
hiccups belongings there is remarkably
little dragons on those rocks spriter
inside this butterfly house with dragons
that it is outside Muppet ripoff Dragon
tongue pedak it's rain cotton had a wing
slice poor opal crumb battle kekkai MUP
with these dragon names with lewis
caroll everyone back home had dragons of
their own if only it were possible no
really believe me I tried as well balki
doesn't believe hiccup even though he
still lives in Berk and she hasn't been
there in 20 years people are not capable
of change hiccup said the stay-at-home
mom of a small child and wife of the
village King before she decided to make
a go of this whole dragon sanctuary
thing baby who grows up to be the
protagonist isn't scared bliss by
something scary is cliche it broke my
heart to stay away but I believed he'd
be safer if I did safer how are you
saying that the Dragons would use your
children to get to you are you
spider-man we have to find them which in
this movie is as easy as just picking a
direction and stumbling on the person
you're looking for if we don't turn up
with dragons careful what you wish
hazard was able to hear Eretz say this
even though he was facing away from her
and she was flying a dragon every dragon
has its secrets and balcony's happens to
know what they all are and how to reveal
them all so how does toothless not know
his body can do this that would be like
me discovering that I had a third hand
my whole life and I didn't notice it
until some lady rub my neck
also you mean after five years of riding
toothless hiccup never learned this easy
ass trick even by accident I know we're
missing and they have tracking dragons
Astrid tells drago that everyone from
Berk is a dragon rider along with
specific information about the main
characters giving him an opportunity to
attack them before they can attack Drago
making Astrid some sort of Bond villains
/ hero movie subjects meet a more
animated arm muscle erotica
I think we did well with this one boss I
think you did well Stuart will you be my
wife once again marriage extortion so he
expects me to believe these kids were
able to get past all the guards and
soldiers hide in the traps with their
dragons and blow their way out of the
traps that were designed to contain
dragons and ultimately almost defeat
this giant army I guess so I guess
eventually she's gonna marry both of
these guys that's there's some adult
themes I'll tell you what yaha now he
had a fight
Drago is standing alone talking to
himself for most of this battle then
it's a good thing I brought a challenger
you can totally kill Drago right now by
the way this movie suddenly got Godzilla
Pacific Rim and Clash of the Titans on
our asses the ocean must get real deep
about ten feet into this Beach because
if it had a normal island Shore there
would be no fucking way this creature
would be able to stay completely some
Berk also I know this is a fantasy world
but ships still cost time and money to
make right why would you waste some
perfectly good ships by not moving them
out of the way for the Alpha dragon to
make his grand entrance it takes more
than a lot to fire up the jomi this is
true of most Berk citizens the dragon
attacks in the first movie yielded no
fatalities but I'm pretty sure no one in
this movie will be killed by fire either
instead of designing a different
Godzilla dragon let's just make -
Godzilla dragons that look exactly the
same but the bad guy dragon is black and
the good one is white because that's
races don't make a children's movie
about dragons goring each other to death
if you don't have the guts to show blood
I guess there are other main characters
fighting in this huge battle but I guess
they're not important or they're flying
around waiting for the movie to pay
attention to them who knows this feels
like a bloody confusing battle where
nobody's dying all of this loss and for
what hiccup still thinks he can talk to
this guy to become unstoppable to rule
the world
I mean yeah if toothless is being
mind-controlled right now what's taking
him so long to kill hiccup moments
earlier we saw toothless's purple fire
wall completely obliterate several giant
weapons yet when stoic takes a toothless
fireball to the chest he still remains
entirely intact get away from him even
though it's totally obvious
toothless was mind-controlled hiccup
decides to blame him for dumb and
infuriating reasons he took all the
dragons not all of them since they
couldn't defeat Drago with hundreds of
adult dragons they're going to try and
defeat Drago with a few baby dragons and
based on how much time is left in the
movie and the kind of movie this is
they're probably going to succeed
bewilder base just
take control of these guys to their
babies they don't listen to anyone
oh sure let's just write our hopes on
that besides this is mine control not
real communication right also if they
don't listen to anyone how are you able
to ride them and guide them where they
need to go they'd be perfectly content
staying back on Pandora right the Alpha
is easily distracted sheep blink Oh
hypnotized dragons only see an
out-of-focus silent film the real you is
inside there somewhere cliche how are
you doing that movie magic also Drago is
letting him do this instead of flying
away or making the alpha male make
toothless hit in with a fireball there
are several other better options but
Drago seems to be a huge fan of
remaining stationary is he incapable of
being remind controlled now wait is this
movie saying as long as the Dragons
can't see the the wildebeest can't
control his brain the wind ripped this
blindfold between shots because first
there is no tear then suddenly there's a
tear hiccup saying is impossibly
impeccable this is Park goddamnit
this is puppet dragon I love this
mission high in time I want to be home
for dinner
love of God sin dr. Khoi anyway a
colleague on great harmonica home has
Jenny please if you don't you be happy
she because God he likes you a popular
one thank you for saving my life
you know nothing Jon Snow yeah
your parents fought against him nobody
lived once he decided to kill her nobody
not one cept you a Mart like that only
comes from being touched by a curse and
an evil curse of that strength from will
of others all glory to the hypnotoad cut
out of here and you see we don't want
you anymore why can't you go back where
you came from